document versus create people aren't
starting they're just not making their
thinking they're pondering they're
strategizing they're debating a lot of
people look at finished products they
look at LeBron today they look at Kobe
today they look at Beyonce today you
know the difference between
understanding who you are versus who you
wish you were I mean if you want to be
respected and really known show the [ __ ]
up enough listening start doing [ __ ]
don't be scared and if you're scared
find somebody who's not scared make them
your partner like it's an action it's
going it's doing and if you're
passionate about something in your world
you can make a big difference
you've got to pop down contest Wine
Library TV work and steam I look like a
hostage in Iraq hello everyone and
welcome to the first episode of Wine
Library TV but here's where people that
pump out content make a mistake they
care about the camera and the lighting
and all that other horse crap it means
nothing everything I believed in was not
possible five years ago anybody can get
in the game and talk about the things
they love the most build a business
around their passion hello everybody
this is Gary Vaynerchuk and this is my
one twenty everybody's Gary Vaynerchuk
complex your time not really it's down
right now you know that's the whole
promise that we never believed before
which was do what you love you always
art do what you love but you won't make
as much money you know the game has
changed you know we talked about all
these products don't be scared to be
multi-dimensional you're not unfocused
you know nobody in this world should
define who you are
you could be so many things you can
crush it doing video blogging and you
can crush it doing blogging I mean it
just comes down to what are you good at
I think that's been turned on its head
do what you love and you'll probably
make more money than you could ever
imagine I think it's much smarter for
you to talk to the world about your
process of going through this then the
advice that you should think you should
be giving them
I think documenting your journey on
medium your own personal blog YouTube
the ice bucket challenge bring it
whoa
SoundCloud anchor you know on and on and
on snapchat on and on and on
hey guys I know I look like Emperor from
Star Wars right now by the phone of you
going through this journey I mean it
would be really cool to have content
right now about when Vera Wang started
learning like literally learning how to
how to create a dress right
we are sitting where the gatekeepers are
no longer in control guys I was in my
office in the dirty jurors right and I
started taping Wine Library TV one of
the great things about the LAV is that
the rocks around a whole lot and some
things are obviously give me for the
show but sometimes things come along
they can stand alone and you need to be
thinking about documenting more than you
need to be thinking about creating what
do you think the appeal is or the daily
I think that I wish I documented all my
shoes to this level because all the
people that think I was smart about
Twitter they don't even know how much
and I think this will do that a lot of
people's a stick the wine stick to what
you know stick to science six stick to
cooking why do we always want other
people to stick to
I don't wanna stick to crap you know
what I want to stick to I want to stick
to what makes me happy I want to want to
execute again you know that's what I
want to do you didn't think was true but
they were 15 16 hours a day you thought
they were hyperbolized and they were
eight or nine you didn't realize every
minute was something you didn't realize
that it's every day I wish I did this
seven years ago I wish you got to see
the last seven years every minute every
day always forever
the world is changing were more
connected and your legacy your maneuver
and your decision-making process has to
start at your long-term legacy big
picture always wins if you're pumping
out good [ __ ] people will follow but if
you for a second
ii don't believe in what you're doing
whether it's your personal brand or the
product you represent you need to get
out now always think of the big picture
the legacy who are you going to be
viewed at when it's all said and done if
I actually from where I started go on to
buy a four billion dollar sports
organization and I documented the entire
journey my words are motivating and I'm
good at that but the reason I knew
dailyvee and the reason I'm documenting
so much is if I can put out a body of
work 40 years from now that showed the
process of a young man that put in the
work had the vision did it the right way
try to help people along the way because
he was trying to build the biggest
building in town by building it not by
tearing everybody else's buildings down
and then I actually accomplished it well
that becomes a real a real a real great
American dream story and this is why I
want to build a massive business because
I want to teach the world that you can
build a billion-dollar Empire ungood
like there's no reason this this
unfortunate narrative that affected a
lot of my friends of Steve Jobs like it
became the move to be a dick because
you're gonna get the best work out of
people I'll tell you right now I'm 40 so
far here's what I got for you people
work way better when you deploy honey
than vinegar I've got much better work
out of people because they're guilted to
let me down versus being scared of me
get the [ __ ] out of here you should
start a pillar show whether it's I mean
vlogging I think is very fascinating you
know you should be doing Instagram
stories and snapchat stories at scale
you should be putting out 7 to 25 pieces
of content on both those platforms a day
and let me explain how don't go fancy
document versus create it's a big it's a
big shift when I say 7 to 25 you say my
god how do I produce 7 to 25 meaningful
things that will have me respected
versus document you got to put out stuff
and you and you got to fabricate it like
when you're like I still can't believe
how many people that live in New York
don't use New York people if I were you
and I had an hour right now calling the
[ __ ] park right right now like I don't
know like go back to your basketball we
would stand outside the garden right
there and be like what do you think
about the mix-up coming season yeah
interview four people one person gets
into a thoughtful conversation he was
the four ball boy in 1957 it's a nice
story and boom you see where I'm going
people aren't starting so you can't
create distribute there's no excuse for
not talking to the world it just doesn't
have to be your thoughts and words every
time my friends the key to content
success is you've got to start
documenting instead of creating let me
tell you how to stop
[Music]